يا إلهي ، يا إلهي ،
أشعر كرائد فضاء
بالتأكيد أين نحن وماذا
سنفعل اليوم هنا نحن مطار نيوارك وسنصعد
في حالة انعدام الجاذبية على g-Force
one وأنت  سوف نحصل على نفس
التجربة مثل الأشخاص في الإصدار ليس لديهم
جاذبية ، تستخدم الشركة طائرة
بوينج 727 معدلة تطير في حركة قطع مكافئ
لخلق دفعات متعددة من انعدام الوزن ،
تأقلم ريتشارد برانسون مع نفسه إلى
الصفر على واحد قبل أن يذهب إلى
الفضاء كما فعل  طاقم الإلهام
أربعة أول رحلة مدنية بالكامل إلى
المدار ، لا تريد أن تكون تجربتك الأولى
في
انعدام الجاذبية
في الفضاء وهو شعور فريد
للغاية وهذا يمنحهم الإطار
لفهمه ،
أنا متوتر قليلاً
نحن جميعًا  اعلم أن التحليق على متن سفينة صاروخية
أمر خطير ولكن ما مدى خطورة هذه
الرحلات فلا يوجد أي خطر أو خطر
فيما نقوم به ، لقد نقلنا 17000 راكبًا
على مدار الـ 16 عامًا الماضية ، ولا توجد
إصابة واحدة ولا مشكلة واحدة ، لذلك لدينا جميعًا
نفس المشكلة.  egulation سلامة كل شيء كما
تفعل تلك الرحلة الموحدة
[موسيقى]
أوه ،
هذا مذهل
[تصفيق]
رائع ،
على عكس رحلات جيف بيزوس أو ريتشارد برانسون ،
هذه الطائرة ليست على صاروخ
موجه إلى الفضاء ، فمجال جوي يبلغ 10 أميال
في 100 ميل يتم تطهيره مقابل g  - فرض
رحلة واحدة ، هناك الكثير من الحديث عن
الرحلات الجوية شبه المدارية التي تعمل على إضفاء الطابع الديمقراطي على
الفضاء ، ولكن هل هذه التجربة هي أقرب
شيء تعرفه شخصًا عاديًا
تمامًا ،
نعم ، نقطة السعر ، أعني أنه لن يقول أحد أن
7500 رخيصة ولكن
يمكن الوصول إليها  أقل بكثير من 28
مليون دولار ،
ما قيمة تجربة انعدام الوزن
مثل هذا فقط
للباحثين عن الإثارة أم أن هناك
قيمة بحثية حقيقية لهذه الرحلات الآن يمكنني
القول أن نصفها عبارة عن بحث ثم
النصف الآخر هو المستهلك الذي يواجهنا  لقد قمنا
بأشياء هي حرفياً في
طليعة المساحات لاختبار كيفية عمل الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
في الجاذبية الصغرى ، وقد أجرينا
تجارب في كيفية تحريك
الدم المجفف بالتجميد للخروج والاختبار  الأشياء في
انعدام الجاذبية أو الجاذبية الدقيقة في الفضاء
باهظة الثمن وغير
واقعية
[ضحك]